Những ngày tháng mấy năm ngàn chim chấp năm 2019, không lâu sau khi biển mắt hòn toàn dài phong,
chứ tình hồ chí miên cùng đò đại điều cấp cao nước Việt Nam rất trụ cộng ngoài,
đã tới thăm tình sback lobster, chút tâm công nghiệp nước kiên và cấp kiên hành đầu của lịch sồ.
Bất chấp cơn mưa lại ngủ răng, đúng đạo công nhân và người dân bật lực kiên hai bên dưới chào đón và đại việc Việt Nam.
Cắt sướng ra của rất tập anh hồ.
Tối rất vui mừng được chuyển đến các bạn lời chào anh em từ những dân Việt Nam,
chút các bạn tiếp tục thành công và thịt vợ.
Bác hồ đã tới nhà máy chỉ tạo máy hạn lặng của răng mắt sở,
chừng kiên những dây chuyển cực kiện đại.
Học tập kinh nghiệm công nghiệp quá, môi hình tổ chức sát xuất hiện đại.
Đây là những những vực mà Việt Nam rất muốn tiếp cận khi ấy để phục vụ tải đi đất lợ.
Tại bảo tăng để chết uran người để lại giống lúc vụ dầu in nhất.
Uran rất thị dầu, người thị dồi, lấy của tử dất và sức người để xây dự chung kia cộng sản.
Vào tức Việt bảo tăng đã tạo người mạnh tinh hạc của nơi sắc như một món quả khi nghiệp.
Chuyến thâm lên số của bác những ngày hài lix sử năm gần chiến trăm năm năm,
góc phần mở đường cho hợp tắc tinh tế kiế tổn với lên số trong công phục xí dẫn chủ nghĩa xa hội ở Việt bác.
Đưa một món đẹp việt số tự hộ chiến trị, mở giọng sản vực tắc thức chất về kinh tế kiế tổ tạo.
Hơn bệnh tập ký đã cho qua, nhưng chúng thâm tình spang lobster của chút thật hồ chi Minh vẫn là biểu tượng đẹp của tình rung ít Việt Nam lên số.
Đúng thời, thế hiện tâm miếng xa và khách bỏ có chuyển đến nước của người.
Những giả chị vẫn tiếp tục xôi sáng hành trình, rực xây Việt Nam hôm nay.